[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning a
Georgia man charged with killing a
teenage girl claims he shot her in
self-defense after a racist attack now
his lawyers want the state's Stand Your
Ground law to clear him 21 year old
Marcus Wilson is charged with felony
murder and aggravated assault in the
death of 17-year old hailey Hutchison
last month the shooting happened on a
highway in Statesboro that's about 50
miles outside of Savannah
mark Strassmann is in Atlanta with more
details on the story mark good morning
to you good morning Gail you know the
issues of race and racism in this story
have real residents for where we are in
2020 mark Wilson is biracial the teenage
girl he shot and killed is white and now
Wilson sisters telling us that first her
brother was the victim of a racist
attack and now race could be an issue in
his legal defense Chelsey Burnett blames
a group of white teenagers for
terrorizing her younger brother Marcus
Wilson and his white girlfriend they
were being called terrible things they
were truly being according to police
records we obtained just after midnight
on June 14th five white teenagers rode
in a Silverado pickup truck a teenage
passenger in the car claims the shooting
was unprovoked that a car pulled up next
to them and fired several shots one went
through the truck's back window and hit
17 year old hailey Hutchinson riding in
the backseat she died Wilson driving the
car faces a charge of felony murder
before a court ordered gag order
Wilson's lawyer said the teens harassed
him in traffic targeting him because
he's black that he only shot at them
after he heard something hit his car
according to police documents the driver
in the truck admitted the teens were
drinking before the shooting police
found a beer can near the shooting scene
suggesting it may have been thrown a
passenger told police he did not
remember anyone throwing it at Wilson's
car hailey Hutchinson's family declined
to speak to us last month her friends
and family remembered her
with this candlelight vigil how their
Ernst is Herat here
you know things happening all the time
violence all over the place but you just
it's not something you imagine happening
to your own we're gonna have to really
look at what was in the mind of mr.
Wilson at the time and that's the
challenge for the defense drew finally
is a criminal defense attorney in
Georgia he's not affiliated with the
case and said the Silverado truck the
teenagers were in could become a focal
point for the defense did he proceed
that that vehicle was going to be used
to push them off the road
did he proceed somehow that this was an
ultimate threat to Ben Wilson's
attorneys argue Georgia's Stand Your
Ground law should protect him it allows
anyone in public to use deadly force if
they believe their own life is on the
line why is he using that defense
because he was protecting himself he was
standing his down and he believes that
his life was in jeopardy
absolutely twenty-six states currently
have Stand Your Ground laws it's been a
controversial legal defense in 2012
George Zimmerman shot and killed 17 year
old Trayvon Martin
he claimed self-defense under Florida
Stand Your Ground law and a jury
acquitted him of murder but Wilson
supporters worried stand your ground
laws won't protect defendants who happen
to be black do you believe if your
brother were white he would have an
easier time establishing a
stand-your-ground defense in court
absolutely I don't think he would have
been charged with felony murder
a judges gag order prevented lawyers
from both sides from talking to us one
of the other white teens in that truck
was charged with obstruction cops say he
withheld information that was important
as they built their case Tony
very interesting complex story they're
out of Georgia Marc thank you very much